ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt um meine lieben freunde in der
letzten episode minecraft mit luca
dürfte tier entscheiden alles in ordnung
[Musik]
in der letzten episode minecraft mit
lukas google jetzt mal bitte ganz kurz
zurück ins wasser hier vorne da kannst
du da drin weitertanzen ihr durftet in
der letzten episode minecraft mit luca
entscheiden ob hier eine brücke hin soll
oder die seerosenblätter und da wurde
menge diskutiert die meisten leute waren
für eine brücke allerdings haben ein
paar minecraft kenner gesagt luca dann
gehen doch deine villiger die ganze zeit
von ewiger insel rüber aufs festland und
das wolltest du doch nicht so wollte sie
doch nie auf der insel haben
da hab ich mir dann auch gedacht
vielleicht ist die brücke gar nicht mal
so eine gute idee
die sache ist allerdings dass mir eine
person angeschrieben hat bestimmt nicht
die haben ja hier vorne ihre ganzen
betten die haben hier ihre arbeit blöcke
und die werden immer wieder hierhin
zurückkehren und dann hier schlafen zu
können um hier beispielsweise an den
schleifstein zu gehen oder an den
schmelzofen von daher habe ich mich dazu
entschieden wirklich hier eine brücke
hin zu bauen das heißt dass mit das ziel
für heute sein was wir allerdings zuvor
machen müssen ist natürlich gekämpft ich
lade video hoch und sage wir machen das
aber davor müssen wir noch ganz viele
andere sachen machen denn mir wurde und
in die kommentare geschrieben als hier
außer sehen die rote beete ja
stattgefunden hat in der letzten folge
dass das doch nicht ich war das aus der
sieben platziert sondern meinen
bauermann
[Musik]
nichts ist gut er hat das wohl gemacht
weil das hier gefahren das feld war und
nicht normale erde das heißt wenn das so
ist dann sollte da keine rote beete von
denen wir hin gesetzt werden und wir
können hier ganz normal die melone
wachsen lassen und ihr ganz normal den
kürbis was mir auch in die kommentare
geschrieben wurde war dass er hier ja
eigentlich gar nicht wie ist denn tui
aber irgendwann mal verloren oder erst
weggelaufen und genau aus diesem grund
möchte ich vier eisen blöcke und einen
kürbis hier unten mit in die kiste
reinlegen denn schmid wissen wir zwar
nicht ob er gestorben ist oder ob er
einfach weggelaufen ist oder irgendwie
die sport ist und ob irgendwas falsch
gemacht haben aber er ist auf jeden fall
nicht mehr da von daher müssen wir auch
das schild hier vorne anpassen ich hoffe
ich krieg da alles drauf ich weiß gar
nicht wer jetzt hier schon alles drin
die karibik
rui wu dann ja die pilze die ich in der
reihenfolge getötet habe für das leder
dann noch die schildkröte und ich glaube
das war's also vergessen haben sollte
ich niemanden von daher eine kurze
schweige sekunde für die verstorbenen
mitglieder unserer insel ich muss
allerdings hier vorne auf den kuhstall
noch mal ganz kurz drauf springen und
mir so ein bisschen lagerfeuer hier
mitnehmen denn die benötigen wir für die
brücke die wir heute bauen werden
ich hab mich da wieder ein bisschen mehr
sagt exel orientiert die hat auch schon
rücken design hochgeladen ich habe es
allerdings ein bisschen anders gemacht
denn die brücke die sie gebaut hat die
geht genau über das wasser drüber
und ich möchte immer noch dass wir die
möglichkeit zumindest haben unter der
brücke her zu fahren so dass wir keinen
großen umweg um die villa der insel
fahren müssen das werdet ihr nachher
alles sehen im video
und ich würde erstmal ganz kurz
einblenden wie ich mir die ganzen sachen
für die brücke zusammen kräfte
ich habe zwar noch nicht mal ansatzweise
alle sachen fertig die ich benötige um
die brücke gleich zu bauen allerdings
wollte ich ganz kurz die teile von
beenden denn ich habe hier vorne bei
unserem kuhställe jetzt mal alle
lagerfeuer abgebaut die wir ja nicht
mehr benötigen weil die kühe ja
perspektive hinten auf die tier insel
kommen sollen und es ist nacht
eventuell keine skelette und dann
eventuell sehen wir ein zombie denn ich
habe einen kommentar gelesen wir haben
ja bisher nur für den creepers sounds
mit dem neuen leute tri max ihr das
schaf hat noch neue rolle bekommen das
können uns noch mal eben können und wir
haben nun auch einen sound für den
zombie ich hoffe mal das habe ich noch
nie gesagt denn auch voll gemein schaft
mit luca dass wir jetzt einen zombie
sehen werden so das ist aber auch egal
freunde dann gehe ich jetzt ganz kurz
einfach schlafen und wir überspringen
die nacht dann bleibt auf jeden fall
irgendwie dran vielleicht sind wir am
heutigen video nochmal irgendwann zombie
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie er dann klingt
dann könnte er dann einfach ein bisschen
genauer hinhören die sache ist
allerdings dass wir auch noch sachen
benötigen für die brücke die wir gar
nicht hier bekommen sondern dafür müssen
wir mal wieder eine kleine reise machen
und hier vorne ins brötchen rein denn
wir benötigen ranken mit den banken
müssen wir bewusst einzige machen also
ab geht's in sumpf reihen
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch hier vorne im sumpf
angekommen meiner lieben freunde wir
haben uns hier tatsächlich noch nie so
richtig in länger drin umgeguckt in
diesem ganzen gebiet hier vorne weil in
sümpfen ist ja auch das ding das hier
eventuell ab und zu hexen delfin flipper
ist damit fischer ich weiß es nicht auf
jeden fall haben wir in sümpfen ziemlich
häufig auch hexen häuser und ich weiß
nicht ob wir davon schon mal welche
gesehen haben oder ob irgendwelche zu
sehen waren als wir durch den sumpf mal
gelaufen sind allerdings sind wir hier
erst mal in erster linie auf und der
ranken die wir für musste stein ziegel
benötigen das habe ich mir nämlich
gedacht dass das vielleicht ganz gut
aussieht bei der brücke wenn die dann
nicht aus normalen stein zielen sind
sondern weil sie am wasser ist ein
bisschen wie muss ich mag auch diesen
look immer so ein bisschen
[Musik]
und da nehme ich mir davon ihr jetzt
erst mal anderthalb sex mit ihr seht und
ich hab schon insgesamt über 100 stück
hier vorne sind auch schafe er kann ich
mir die wolle auf jeden fall mitnehmen
die wird wirklich sehr wichtig sein für
unseren leuchtenden mir demnächst
irgendwann mal bauen werden
ich weiß gar nicht sind wir hier vorne
schon mal lange laufen auch nicht so
dahin ist das village atdorf im wasser
für euch zum verständnis da ganz hinten
wohne ich irgendwo und hier ja noch gar
nicht ich freue mich auf jeden fall auf
einer der nächsten folgen wo wir dann
endlich wieder auf entdeckungsreise
gehen werden ich glaube sogar dass mache
ich in der folge übermorgen da werden
wir allerdings hinten in richtung pilz
biom mal fahren mit einem brötchen weil
da waren wir wirklich noch nie in der
richtung und haben uns ja damals mit dem
bildschirm zufriedengegeben und sage da
kommen ihm einfach die kühlmittel dann
halt wieder zurück wo ist mein boot nach
vorne ist mein boot schwer verlaufen
und da sind wir wieder bei unserer
kleinen insel hier angekommen ihr seht
auch schon hier vorne sind ein paar mehr
fichten bäume auf jeden fall gewachsen
der hier vorne der hier und der das
finde ich ganz schön dass wir zu
verschiedenen baumarten haben sieht sehr
sehr geil sehr perfekt sieht sehr geil
und sehr verwirrt aus wenn ich es mal
ganz kurz erzählen lassen ab das finde
ich auch zuerst mal sind uns einig wie
kannst du reden ohne dass sie auf den
knopf drücken
[Musik]
also folgende situation ich habe gerade
20 minuten lang diese ganzen sachen hier
zusammengebracht die ich benötige für
die brücke allerdings fehlt mir noch
mehr schwarz eichenholz für schwarz
eichenholz zäune
das heißt wir müssen irgendwo jetzt
hinreisen wo wir schwarz eichen hatten
dementsprechend würde ich sagen
schnappen wir uns unser boot oder steht
dass hier vor
die kommt heute noch irgendwann wir
laufen hier vorne unseren weg runter und
schnappen uns unser brot was wir hier
vorne gelagert hatten und fahren noch
mal ganz kurz in die richtung da hinten
denn in der nächsten folge wenn wir die
erkundungstour machen möchte ich ja dort
hinten fahren gar keinen sinn dass ich
da gerade in zeiten die nicht wo ich
ihnen sage ich will auf jeden fall da
hinfahren
seht ihr noch meine fresse dass das
schwein hat er denn ich finde dass er
wirklich so unfassbar ist dass unsere
komplette mannschaft welt einfach lebt
sage ich mal also so dumm dass jetzt
vielleicht klingen mag aber das normale
der vielen da rumspringt dass er hinten
an das schwein rumläuft und bin ich
irgendwie eine unterirdische charme und
kuhstall habe okay das ist blöd wir
haben einen kuhstall aber der soll ja
perspektivisch weg ich würde allerdings
sagen wir fahren wieder in die richtung
hier vorne dann hab ich hab vorhin schon
hingeguckt das sah sehr vielversprechend
aus und standen eine menge bäume
ich weiß dass hier vorne die ganze bäume
die hier rumstehen dass das alles eichen
sind wir brauchen allerdings schwarz
eichen und ich denke mir eine schwarze
wenn also wenn ich eine schwarze wäre
ich würde dort anfangen mich hin zu
pflanzen wo vielleicht normal reichen
auch sind also die leute beziehungsweise
die personen die die ich vergleich
gerade bäume mit menschen
aber ich meine fische sind ja auch er im
wasser bei anderen fischen als dass sie
an land dann plötzlich chillen mit
irgendwelchen löwen das wird ja nicht so
gut zusammenpassen von als würd ich
sagen schauen wir einmal hier vorne und
hier haben wir auch ganz ganz ganz ganz
viele bäume da ist vielleicht ist er ja
die eine oder andere schwarze mit dabei
ich habe keine ahnung was das schwarze
ist in minecraft als ich die letzten
male gespielt habe gab es sowas noch
nicht viele werfen ja auch immer vor
lukas schätzte man ein buch geschrieben
damals immer mein perfektes jahr das
zappa 56 jahre her da hatte das spiel
noch nicht diese ganzen sachen die sie
jetzt haben das hier vorne sind glaube
ich ganz normal erreichen oder also wenn
ich die nehmen das ist ein eichenstamm
genau den den setze ich darauf wieder
hin so viel ordnung muss sein
ich befinde mich hier vorne indem blumen
biom sehe ich gerade sogar also haben
wir sogar schon mal die ganzen vier
teile geholt die wir benötigten minister
[Musik]
sind nicht hat etwas umgeschrieben das
ist so schön hier oder es ist echt süß
hier alles ich mag dass sie auf jeden
fall sehr genau wir haben eine menge
schafe das ist sehr gut ich hab auch
examen
[Musik]
geht das thema mein gott ich das ding
mit dem sei keine insel
ich wusste ich jetzt ja da mal wieder
was dazugelernt also bienenstöcke oder
bienen nektar oder wie die heißen
sollten wir nicht abbauen
das habe ich halt zu bieten schon mal
gemacht den fehler habe ich dachte wenn
ich mit einer achse bauen dann kann
nichts mitnehmen
egal wie konzentrieren erst mal ganz
kurz auf die schafe und auf die ganze
wolle die ich hier mitnehmen wenn mir
wurde auch in die kommentare geschrieben
luca angst vor den dingen hier die wohl
doch in die kommentare geschrieben luca
bevor du den leuchtturm mit wolle baust
macht als nie bei ihnen die mit keramik
oder beton ich weiß nicht mehr genau was
bei geschrieben wurde dicker geht das
hier weit runter ja ich muss mir
überlegen aber ich denke mir lieber
wolle haben als nicht haben lieber haben
als brauchen gutes zitat von mir
wir nehmen hier vorne bei den schafen da
ist ein doch einst alter warum sind denn
je so viele von diesen bienen nestern
[Musik]
ich bin auch so ein baby schaaf wir
müssen irgendwann demnächst wenn wir die
tiere insel machen müssen wir auf jeden
fall die ganzen scharfen mitnehmen das
ist echt unfassbar schöne dieses bsg
dankeschön dieses bio ist generell
ziemlich schön dass bienen dem
bienenstock lasse ich jetzt einfach mal
hier nicht weiß nicht wie ich das ding
mitnehmen kann oder nicht sind das
hirsch wahrzeichen das sind auch ganz
normale eichenstämmen ich weiß auch gar
nicht gibt es hier waren doch vorhin so
bäume die wann genau die hier dass sie
könnten eventuell schwarz zeichen sein
weil die sehen so ein bisschen schwärzer
aus auf jeden fall
und das sind schwarze stimme perfekt
animiert davon jetzt auf jeden fall ein
bisschen was mit wenn euch das gerade
gefällt was wir machen also dieses
bisschen erkunden und so weiter und so
fort dann müsst ihr auf jeden fall
übermorgen einschalten denn da kommt er
um 20 uhr die neue folge online wo wir
dann richtig erkunden werden
also ist wirklich ein boot nehmen werden
wir werden uns auch ein reisebett
mitnehmen das wurde mir die kommentare
geschrieben luca du braucht jeden fall
eine reise wert wenn du unterwegs bist
das werde ich mir dann auf jeden fall
machen sodass wir unterwegs auch
schlafen können nicht den ganzen stress
haben allerdings wird übermorgen wieder
eine folge kommen die wir komplett
unserer welt und einer erkundungstour
wird mitunter freue ich mich wirklich
extrem darauf geben die richtung müssen
wir auf jeden fall auch demnächst einmal
ein bisschen weitergehen finde ich auch
sehr sehr sehr sehr geil hier alles 42
schwarz eichenstämme sollten auf jeden
fall reichen aber ich will hier trotzdem
endlich gern noch mal ein bisschen
umgucken mit dem see da vorne mit der
brust und so ist schon schön hier alles
meine welt wenn schon richtig froh
darüber dass wir das hier alles so das
ist alles so geworden ist
ich will nach hause ich weiß nicht was
das hier ist
aber das war jedoch noch nicht schon
dass das war jedoch vorher noch nicht
oder nicht blöd ist das also ich hab so
was schon mal gesehen aber das war hier
noch nicht als wieder vorher gelingt
sind wir haben eine angel mit reparatur
wir haben eine menge kohle weizen gold
wer noch was sie auf jeden fall nichts
mehr was ist das also ich glaube wir
haben wirklich schon mal sowas entdeckt
in unserer welt aber ich bin doch genau
hier will ich doch wohin auch lang
gefahren wir sind auch hier lassen und
dann nach vorne hin das war dann doch
noch nicht jetzt noch mehr
[Musik]
das finde ich ein ganz komisches buch
des verschwindens ist hier noch mehr
oder dass das davon ist auch noch was
ich kann ich das denn die ganze zeit
übersehen wenn dass sie die ganze zeit
gewesen sein sollte hier haben wir in
der kiste sogar ein smaragd wir haben
das fleisch dass ich mal hier dann
wieder kohle weit sogar eine schatzkarte
hier drin hier ist auch eine kiste wir
haben auch sogar noch eine schatzkarte
was geht denn jetzt ab das habe ich ja
noch nie gesehen dass wir davon so viele
auf einmal hatten mehr ist hier auf
jeden fall nicht denn hier geht es
ziemlich weit runter also die vier
kisten die hier waren haben wir auf
jeden fall gelautet
mein boot befindet sich da vorne ich
habe jetzt ein bisschen schiss weil die
sonne bereits untergegangen ist also
schnell hier rein und euch eine ganz
kurze time netz wieder zurück nach hause
suchen
[Musik]
und da sind wir wieder zu hause
angekommen ich pack mal wieder hier
vorne so dass wir hier direkt in unser
haus gehen können
ich hoffe mal dass jetzt nicht hier
irgendwo ein krieg hat schild oder ein
zombie aber dann könntet ihr euch
zumindest mal den neuen zombie sound
anhören aber wir haben hier tatsächlich
niemand kann schlafen was mit den
updater wir können uns nun mit unseren
frisch gewonnenen schwarzen stemmen
allerdings auf das hauptziel für heute
konzentrieren nämlich auf die brücke
denn wir müssen zu allererst erstmal
einige zäune machen zwölf bereichen auf
gar keinen fall dabei auf jeden fall
noch mehr stöcker und wir brauchen auch
noch 18 von den normalen zellen damit
sollten wir jetzt glaube ich alles
endlich mal zusammen haben für die
brücke ich finde so crazy dass wir
eigentlich heute nur die brücke bauen
wollten und jetzt ist die situation dass
wir quasi schon da hinten jetzt eine
neue unterwasser ruin oder wie auch
immer das heißt keine ahnung entdeckt
haben wir waren im schwarzen stammen
biome fällt keine ahnung wie das ding
heißt jetzt aber endlich den ganzen kram
sie beiseite und wir konzentrieren uns
auf unsere brücke ihr seht schon ich
habe hier vorne den steg abgebaut und
hier auch den steg abgebaut und hier vor
noch die ganzen seerosenblätter denn
hier kommt die brücke selbstverständlich
hin zuallererst benötigen wir zwei
bemooste stein ziegel bzw
auch erst mal noch ein bisschen sand der
kommt nämlich hierhin und die brücke die
ich mir hier nebenan vorbereitet habe
beziehungsweise in der kate gefällt
schon mal aufgebaut habe die soll hier
und hier lang laufen hier vorne machen
wir dann den weg weiter genauso wie hier
vorne das heißt hier kommt ein bisschen
erde hin und dann hier auch zwei
bruchstein stufen so dass wir hier
weiter so hoch laufen können hier müssen
wir jetzt ganz kurz warten dass ihr dass
das gras von hier über geht hier drauf
so dass wir dann mit der schaufel
rechtsweg machen können allerdings
nutzen wir für euch hier vorne nun
erstmal die fichtenholz falten
denn die hier sollen so ein bisschen die
erste stufe sein und dann geht die
brücke hierüber von hier kommen jetzt
auf jeden fall eins zwei drei vier und
hier auch noch mal ein zwei drei vier
fichtenholz stufen in die richtung und
da drauf das setzen wir
nun die lagerfeuer die wir uns geholt
haben nämlich 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 und dort
mit der schaufel mit rechts drauf das
finde ich immer noch sehr schön dass das
so eine art stieg darstellt und dann
wenn wir quasi hier rüber gehen geht das
dann quasi los vier stück in die
richtung und dann gehts hoch
dann können wir quasi wenn das hier hoch
gibt darunter her um hier sind noch die
rosenblätter hier liegt auch noch kohle
um das sollten wir nicht verzagen
[Musik]
der typ mit seinen mit gabeln ist das ne
der ist schon wieder zurück
lasst mich in ruhe mit den komischen
gabel der attackiert schuhe hier total
alter es geht ihm aber jetzt tot schule
kommen hoch kommt er ganz schnell mal
eben hier runter ich weiß nicht aber da
und noch ist ja hier ist ja auf jeden
fall also erstmal mit dem eisen hier
rechts so dass er sich ein bisschen halt
und jetzt die leine und jetzt können wir
hoffentlich giulia vorne wieder
hochziehen alter das kann doch nicht
wahr sein verteidigte er mich um meine
insel hier vor diesem komischen spies
gabel idioten und geht dabei fast selber
drauf hier kommt sie kommt auf sehr gut
okay dann haben wir für wiederholt das
ist doch wieder wahnsinn wir wollen
einfach eine verdammte brücke bauen und
kommen hier die dazu ins straucheln so
wir brauchen das hier und wir brauchen
die wir mussten stein ziege stufen
denn die brücke soll ich hier dann
bisschen schwierig also hier vorne bei
euch auf jeden fall auch noch erde hin
und dann machen wir hier vorne auf die
ecke auf jeden fall einen von diesen
laub teilen hiervon auch noch einen
hinter muss man noch die erde hier so
ein bisschen weiter und hier dann auch
bewusste stein ziegel stufen zack zack
und hier fichtenholz wir noch keine 50
stufen die fangen es hier an
denn die hier muss noch mal ganz kurz
weg und hier kommen noch eine
fichtenholz falltür hin die habe ich
hier vorne und zack und darauf jetzt
auch die lagerfeuer die wir dann auch
wieder mit unserer schaufel hier kurz
ausmachen zack zack zack zack und zeigt
hier dass sie so quasi denn von der
einen seite so roos losgeht ich stehe
voll neben der spur gerade merke ich
nehme schon wieder mehr als zwei stunden
auf und wollte eigentlich diese brücke
direkt zu beginn fertig bauen da jetzt
haben wir so viel erlebt es tut mir leid
dass ich wieder voll neben der spur
stellen auch dass ich die ganze hier
wieder drüber gucke denn davon habe ich
wieder die ganze zeichnungen wie die
brücke werden soll denn dieser schwarz
eichenholz ohne die hab ich ich muss
mich erst mal ganz kurz sammeln
liegen wir allerdings eine generelle
halterung für unsere komplette brücke
und dafür habe ich mir hier schon dieser
gemeißelt ein ziegel gemacht die wir
dort einfach hinsetzen und dann können
wir hier an der seite die teile so
runter bauen so dass die brücke sich
dort so ein bisschen festhält genau das
gleiche jetzt auch hier auf der anderen
seite er machen wir auch einfach ihr
rennen drunter und das hier müssen wir
zeit sehr weit runter ziemlich will es
aber einfach für mein verständnis und
für meinen inneren mongolei runterziehen
damit ich weiß die brücke schwebt da
nicht irgendwie dumm in der luft herum
jetzt einmal ganz kurz luft holen
es gab eine schraube runtergefallen ich
dann danach auf jeden fall völlig neben
der spur und kommt doch nicht mehr
richtig vernünftig geradeaus
kommentieren von der blende ich euch
auch hier einfach mal ganz kurz mit time
lab sein wie ich die brücke mehr oder
weniger fast schon fertig gebaut habe
doch dann hatte ich ein paar probleme
mit dem tag und da machen wir jetzt
weiter ist auch falsch
das kannst du doch nicht so spielen
lassen hier für die bilder so jetzt
sollte es allerdings passen und das hier
vorne
das kann ich gerade auf meiner zeit noch
nicht richtig erkennen wie ich das
gemacht habe ich glaube ich habe das so
gemacht sodass wir ja genauso habe ich
das gemacht allerdings nur von der seite
so dass wir uns hier den kopf nicht
stoßen das ist eigentlich ganz nice sack
hier wieder rauf und hier vorne habe ich
dann noch mal zwei
ich bin ich immer wirklich gerade
überfragt ich habe hier die fichten
holzstufen hingesetzt das ist hier alles
gerade live in der aufnahme freunde also
wir sind nicht live aber man darf sich
auch mal verbauen und ich glaube das ist
gerade wirklich und ich glaube das merkt
man auch wenn ich total unterzuckert bin
darf ich eine ganz komische folge hier
heute ich glaube das ist doch die mit
abstand komisch befolge die ich bisher
hochgeladen habe ich weiß gar nicht was
ich hier von falsch gesetzt habe ich
glaube die hier waren ist die falsche
oder wenn ich die so hinsetzt ja das
passt auf jeden fall hier die
fichtenholz falsche weg und hier dann
haben wir die auf jeden fall auch
richtig zackig wieder falsch so passt
auf jeden fall
ich weiß nicht was ich wie ich das hier
gemacht habe ich bin euch mal hier das
foto ein
damit ihr wisst was ich gerade nicht
weiß ich nehme ganz kurz die erde hier
weg die ich da provisorisch hingesetzt
habe um dann einfach mal ganz kurz zu
gucken ob das jetzt so richtig aussieht
von der seite also ich habe ja gerade
mal den screenshot eingeblendet aber es
sieht tatsächlich so aus die hier vorne
sollen nicht sein die bei euch noch mal
ganz kurz eben ab also du hier vorne
kommst du weg und was sie auch noch
drankommen sind nun die laternen die
kommen nämlich dorthin und hier vorne
kommt eine hin und hier und hier vorne
kommen auch noch mal zwei hinzu und
sagte dass wir so ein bisschen
beleuchtung haben und das müsste sein
ich glaube die haben sich mach dir den
weg noch mal weiter dann kann man hier
direkt drauf gehen
hier geht es dann quasi weiter hier geht
es weiter das ist fertig hier ist welche
kommt man runter das hier muss gerade so
sein damit hier die das gras noch immer
wächst und das geile ist halt jetzt wenn
wir ein boot haben da laufe ich mal ganz
kurz nach hinten hin ich weiß nicht mehr
ob das boot da noch stand oder wo wir
aus dem boot ausgestiegen sind aber ich
glaube ja das war ja hier vorne als wir
von der insel zurück kamen genau hier
stets damit können wir das dann auch
noch mal ganz kurz testen ob es wirklich
möglich ist dass wir drunter her fahren
direkt zehn fehler mache ich nicht
normal dass ich da die seerosenblätter
um mehr und mehr gefahr sie selber alles
kaputt mache aber ich glaube das sollte
jetzt klappen und die brücke sieht auf
jeden fall
die todesnacht richtig gut mit rein
finde ich dass wir gut hingekriegt und
ist jedoch alles proportionales und wenn
jetzt unter helfern sieht so aus wir
sehen halt kurz unsere herzliche fresse
aber wir kommen unter her und das war in
dem video was ich gesehen hatte war das
leider nicht möglich aber wir haben es
jetzt möglich gemacht meine lieben
freunde und die brücke und das ist das
geil ist nicht nur von oben nass aus
sondern auch von unten sieht dieser geil
aus und die hat sich die idee ist es die
funktioniert ich packe das man auch
gerade ein ganz kurzes stückchen weiter
hier damit wir dann nachher besser
einsteigen können die brücke ist auf
jeden fall fertig ich freue mich auf
jeden fall
das fühlt sich gar nicht so an als
hätten wir das jetzt wirklich geschafft
das hier ist doch
aber ich mache das hier auch so oder
und das wollen wir auch treppen hin
machen ich weiß es nicht ich könnte mir
unseren kommentare schreiben ob ich hier
noch irgend was man verändern soll ich
finde so auf jeden fall sehr schön die
brücke erfüllt ihren zweck und auch
ihren zweck den zweck hat sich auf jeden
fall meine lieben freunde wenn euch die
heutige episode minecraft mit luca
gefallen hat dann einen daumen hoch
unter dem video abonniert main kanal
weil es noch kein teil der lokalzeitung
klickt auf die glocke um eine
benachrichtigung zu bekommen sobald ich
ein neues video hochladen das wird
übermorgen um 20 uhr der fall sein und
ich wollte mich auch jetzt noch mal ganz
kurz dafür entschuldigen dass sich folge
jetzt so komisch irgendwie zu ende
gegangen ist ich merke einfach wie ich
selbst total hunger habe ich habe total
bock auf irgendetwas süßes und ich merke
einfach wie ich hier bin ich werde weil
ich hier schon wieder so lange
aufgenommen habe sollte eigentlich gar
nicht so eine lange freude gewährten wie
es jetzt heute doch dann wieder geworden
ist allerdings haben wir ganz ganz
wieder lebt sondern der geile folge wir
sehen uns übermorgen wieder abonniert
einen kanal weist der hypo seit ich habe
schon gesagt
[Musik]